[Music]
good morning John it's Friday September
7th now I know that there's some people
out there who have been talking about my
lack of moral combat knowledge and the
fact that scorpion never ups people
spines out only sub-zero people spines
out but that is wrong while it is true
that sub-zero traditional fatality is
the spine Ripper and scorpions
traditional fatality is the toasty I
have documented proof in the form of a
YouTube video that is either link over
there or down there depending on where
you are that in Mortal Kombat deception
sub-zero upgrades to ripping someone's
entire skeleton out through their lower
back and scorpion uses sub-zero spider
perfect allottee so ripping out
someone's spine is technically a
scorpion fatality it's true that it is
not the traditional scorpion fatality
however sub-zero wasn't going to fit the
meter of the song so I had to fall back
on the lesser-known of the spine ripping
crazy
Mortal Kombat duo scorpion you can see
it in the video if you are okay with
that kind of thing
mom's beware okay everybody agree that
that's enough talking about spine
ripping as an apology for all that talk
about gore here's cameos fatality which
consists mostly of being adorable doing
what we call kneading the biscuit dough
and occasionally drooling it's actually
not very pleasant it happens on your
chest who she's like drooling into your
mouth but otherwise it's completely
adorable and so far she's never tried to
rip my spine out through my lower back
so preferable to video games just for a
second I want to talk about the happy
dance project because I want everyone to
remember that there is a happy dance
project and if we don't talk about it
people will be like right I have to do a
happy dance I have to go to the pyramids
and they'll be like oh but it's tomorrow
that it's due October 1st people October
1st
do you happy dances maybe a little bit
too excited maybe not that's threat
level of excitement I think I might be I
think that's right the whole excitement
a little drugs for oh hi I'm
nerdfighters I don't think that the
Happiness Project is a very good idea
and it's very exciting to think a five
minute long video of people doing their
happy dances and lots of different cool
places it's like that guy where the heck
is that
dancing stupid dancing guy except we're
totally carbon neutral because we don't
have to fly around the world to do it
because there are lots of us all over
the place
that's exciting John I'm really glad
that you like the book people who
noticed my haircut I'm really not did
you like my haircut people who liked the
song I'm really really really glad you
like my song it's hard to process that
people like my music I've always wanted
to make music and I've never had a
reason to and the fact that you people
are there one thing need to do it I have
to do it and I have to do it well or
else you'll be mad at me
and you'll know if I don't work hard so
thank you for rewarding me and for being
there and for liking it even though I
suck at playing guitar I have something
that very few other musicians have and
that I am extremely lucky for because I
don't probably deserve it as much as the
rest of those musicians do I'm applying
the label musician to myself very
loosely maybe I'm more like a stand-up
comedian with a guitar
I don't know and John obviously I have
you to thank for getting me into this
whole brotherhood 2.0 mess in the first
place and challenging me to write and
perform an original song every Wednesday
I have a repertoire now I like a Johnny
Cash sounding song and I have like pop
punk songs and I have like advantage
ient sounded song is very exciting did I
mention that Katherine and I are gonna
go see the ivy Giants we are on the 23rd
which is our first wedding anniversary's
kind of perfect really anyway
I should talk more about all that
important stuff that you were talking
about in relation to deep economy but I
didn't because I had to talk about
scorpions fatality so maybe we'll do
that next week sorry
I'll see you on Monday